[Musique]
les scènes d'horreur se déroulent
toujours au
[Musique]
sous-sol avec un sens de la mise en
scène appliqué les les les les jeunes
femmes qu'on présente sont cagoulé elles
sont attachées à un tuyau men noté
quasiment quand elles ne sont pas
attachées sur une croix de
Saint-André il a un tarif qui est exposé
pour percer les seins du guette il vous
en coûtera temps pour la petite histoire
il y a des aiguilles à tricoter qui sont
laissé à disposition de ces
messieurs pour lui faire boire son urine
il vous en coûtera tant pour la violer
il vous en coûtera tempant et plus le
sice était horrible plus les tarifs
[Musique]
montaient